coming up next week terrorism biofuels
and mini plenary welcome to the agenda
how to counter radicalization where do
you start and is terrorism legislation
that's strong enough on Tuesday the
Parliament will hold court on the
creeping threat of terrorism invited
speakers include an Islamic consultant
from the Belgian prison service a
belgian federal prosecutor and the chair
of the European police Confederation
later on in the week also look out for
Europe on TVs interview with another
invitee Robert Wainwright the director
of Europol post Paris attacks security
was beefed up outside important
landmarks and buildings like the
Parliament how much money should be
spent on security or he is a figure 190
billion euros that's how much member
states spend outside of the EU budget
kid the money allocated for EU military
and civilian operations be better spent
the foreign affairs and security and
defence committee but funding to a vote
on Tuesday switching gears and coming
across a little bit wacky it's over to
the Environment Committee we're making a
case for seaweed and waste they've not
lost a plot these are just two examples
of the so-called new generation biofuels
the mep s will make a push for to wean
off dependency on traditional fossil
fuels all the eyes were dotted all the
t's crossed but a year and a half after
a successful
initiative to trigger legislation to
make Walter a basic human right well no
lot has really happened q protests
outside the parliament in March for its
part the Parliament did follow through
with a draft report so what are the next
steps remembers the Environment
Committee will take another look at the
report on a Tuesday and finally making
its return to the Brussels chamber the
mini plenary and this time it's got a
social agenda mep s will discuss the
multi-annual financial framework for the
years ahead factory fires in Bangladesh
and mark a hundred years since the
armenian genocide and as all we have
this agenda take care and enjoy a week